all right so we have the jiggler and
actually saying that out loud makes me
realize it kinda sounds dirty but it's I
don't think it's dirty
iczer feel like I watched a very
deranged National Geographic episode
like how a jiggler works once again this
design is great it's how do you even
describe it it's it sort of looks like a
dumbbell if I that's the best I can
describe it so you know that that
whistles it has a bunch of holes in it
and they take this thing in and they're
like oh hey we can take care of this and
it turns out it's a baby and can survive
unless it has some kind of juice in it
they feed it drawings right yeah because
that's what it eats and in purple
whatever's yeah purple yeah that's right
the pro whatever is do we ever find out
what the juices they spewing out we just
know okay it's just like the mother's
juice or whatever that's not bad too but
regardless so they got and they tried to
take him back because if he doesn't have
the juice he also stretches I guess like
his butt was running around like for a
happy episode and they find him to give
back to his mother which is this giant
thing and I love the way the mother gets
angry because it doesn't just sort of
like change shape or get mean eyes like
the color goes really rapid it remind me
like the only thing I can think of is
when you're at the last level I'm like
an eight big game and you're fighting
the bad guy and his life force is
getting lower and lower and they start
to shine it looks like that I always
loved that effect so I loved seeing it
when it gets angry um and they say no no
it's it's it doesn't recognize the scent
it is very true of a lot of a lot of
animals and they throw it in the mama
juice whatever that was and the mother
recognizes it again so yeah they're all
those episodes I don't quite know what
to say I didn't see the snail again no I
did the only other thing I'll say real
fast is the I love the opening with the
what is that cold where they have the
singing auto-tune auto-tune yeah I love
the auto-tune singing cuz it just starts
off with that they don't explain
happen it looks like something really
horrific happened if there's a village
not just a village like this kingdom at
a castle on fire and it was to save a
watermelon that doesn't talk does it say
anything it could just be a watermelon
and they just drop it off at this house
and they're like there you go Stanley
the watermelon it doesn't say thank you
or anything it just they just walk off
and I'm like oh my god to keep just like
a slaughter of people because he's mad
like does that ever come into play again
or is that all we ever hear of that um
that particular scene has not yet come
back into play I don't know if it ever
will it may or may not it's bright it's
far the funny is that they just never
reference it the cat Stanley does return
okay so the woman does return okay yes
but in terms of what they were saving
him from and that how he ate the
computer that gave him the auto-tune
voice that's never explained no okay oh
God I'm glad Stanley comes back as he he
was a vital character I could tell you
know he well could be he probably is for
all I know
oh but yeah so and did he ever see why
he also had like the hot dogs it's like
some of their food he had their two orbs
family that's Stanley's family the hot
dogs the marshmallows that's Stanley's
family watermelon and his family are
safe there are two water mills that
means they had to mate and somehow they
get hot dogs and marshmallows
yeah come on it makes perfect sense
obviously I I can't think too much what
to say about this episode I guess sort
of the mother not recognizing the child
because of the scent I guess that sort
of interesting information to give about
how a lot of animals work but I guess it
was sad seeing this little thing they
unintentionally kidnapped doc he slowly
died but it turns out okay in the end so
what can you say about this
well I remember when I was like younger
and everything and like everyone smile
you come across like a bird that had
fallen out of a nest or something like
and as a kid you want to help and take
care of this animal in everything not
realizing that what you're actually
doing is probably harming the animal
more than helping it and I think this is
a great example of actually just that
where oh we're just gonna take this
little creature that's following us and
take it home as a pet and then they
start kind of messing things up and
everything they do to try to help it
isn't helping it's making everything
worse the only way to make this animal
better is to give it back to its parents
hmm then even y-yeah and even then when
giving it back you know they already saw
the harness or ahead just with the scent
that they put on whoo that's actually
really interesting this is why I need
you I need you I want to put any of this
together but it's a very very good point
because you're right I think a lot of
kids do and have done that they make
kids stories about that house it always
in no just returned to its mother and it
goes back find it's like no wait preview
like you know probably quiet or
something so no actually it's a very
legitimate point never put that together
no it's that's a very very good point
yeah so I guess it is sort of teaching
in a sense whether it knows it or not I
mean it is they're teaching kids about
like you know just as much as you want
help an animal it's serve - I should say
like a stray animal like a bird or
something like that you know it is
probably best just to let it be because
all right yeah I don't know okay you're
right not little kids you know an adult
can probably you know a person that
knows what they're doing should do it
yeah you know but but not a little kid
because yeah you do see that sometimes
like a kid picks up like a baby
something or other and yeah we either
get bitten by it or they take it in
think he'll be best for them and yeah
it's actually doing more yeah so a very
good point
so um anything else about the jiggler um
the other thing seem that I actually
really liked is where the jiggler starts
like spewing out all the kook and then
like he explodes and then you have Finn
and Jake covered in this pinkish stuff
that looks very bloody SH exactly it was
kind of he's just like oh my god we just
murdered them and they're covered in all
this like what looks like blood and it's
kind of like
if they actually ended it right there it
would have looked like they just
slaughtered this poor little yeah
and I liked how it was kind of like that
whole Wow that kind of looks really like
deadly and dangerous but at the same
time it's like okay he's not dead
everything's fine I always heard that's
how like yeah I was just like - evil
then - again and I guess that's how they
got past like some of the rating
problems is that they change the color
of the blood like they'll have green
blood and blood and stuff and I guess
sometimes if you just changed the color
to something else you don't more
impressionable audiences don't look at
it's like Oh blood they just look at as
oh that can be rosebery or something
like that so um so yeah in a fight just
changing the colour of something well
when impact it can have I mean just very
quickly
yeah so Eddie Murphy tried a net as an L
sketch it was hilarious I changed the
color of his skin it's fine Gumby know
you've never seen the episode where he
goes around a white person know you have
some research to do but if you haven't
either look it up I'm sure us on YouTube
it's one of the funniest sketches you
will ever see so we're gonna look that
up after this actually okay so cool and
anything else before the sign up here
nothing agin the Oh besides the singing
um as this like to show actually
progresses there's a quite a bit more
singing that actually like takes place
and not just from thin but from other
characters as well doesn't else I have
like the outer - no only finish finish
the only one with auto-tune
can't wait for that so see you next time